ronnie i had to call him i heard he was
depressed he put out a tweet
that everyone was alarmed about what did
he say
unhappy monday 2020 the year of sadness
just when you think things are getting
to be a little better
something brings you back down sucks so
i called him
he was upset his cat died i know how
that goes
although two days later it was a
wednesday topless hump day he had
so he was back in good form again i see
yeah it was momentary
i called ronnie because i was afraid
like he was going off the deep end
this is the time of year he usually
throws his big block party
and uh now he's all alone yeah yeah no
end of summer party this weekend
it was the perfect weather for it it was
great and i sat in my backyard and look
at the [ __ ] water
by myself well ron i'm hoping this will
cheer you up your mom is on the phone
yeah don't be sad ronnie your best loans
are still ahead of you
inside your balls like this
my balls he's got in other words
he has a lot of loads ronnie feels sad
because he's getting old
you feel time slipping away ronnie you
know headstart time
you shove an hourglass up your ass
i got a whole cuckoo clock just shoved
up my coach
right now you have a you have a cuckoo
clock shoved up your
cooch and that's how you stop time
that's how you stop time
i don't know if you're cheering ronnie
up i'm looking at a lot of good advice
you know what your grandma phyllis used
to say
it's always darkest before
you know a lot of people blame the
mother for depression in the child
is that right i didn't know that robin's
not depressed about quarantine
she's handling it just fine yeah yeah
well robin should be depressed
robin's [ __ ] has been empty so long
they turned it into a halloween store
[Laughter]
it's a halloween store and they turn
robin's [ __ ] into a halloween store
see ronnie your mother
ronnie you know what your mom gets
bummed down too
but then i sing a song don't worry
be horny i'll drink it
[Music]
go
[Music]
ready
later